as the golden knights advance to the Stanley
Cup Final moved up the boards by hinen kept
Alive by the golden Knight shot by Maro covered
up by ainger late start here in Dallas second
of the twin bille Cy Albert Eddie EK Brian bue
following Bruins win over the panther shot by
White Cloud but that that depth at the center
ice position you you know exactly what you're
going to get and they're pretty special here's
champ Ben back shot of that CL by Hill what a
move there by Ben right between the legs here
hints on the four check watch the play here yeah
little forehand between the legs reverse five
hole and then just get the puck to the net and
Joe pavelski looking for any kind of a rebound
that was just a beautiful play there by hint and
Ben face out by Thomas Shen back out to
the right side save made by Hill pocket P
had it takeen away here's eel down the
left wing joined by Maro and a save by
ainger Big Time stop there the old stop
used to drop your film in there and then
a two-on one eel with the opportunity and as
bu said not allowed to shoot at his AER stop
mov the punch ahead kept Alive by the golden
knights got by amio saved by ainger here's
panelo straight away down low w acoss score AO
power play goal beautiful pass play one nothing
Vegas look at the goal here beautiful passing play
Stevenson toah over to amario you see anything
else there Bush I asked you the question
you're down one and then you almost give
up one back door I do not know how Kar missed
that one Robertson kicked out by Aiden Hill
here's Conor on the steel Conor
with a shot turned aside by
ainger Bon Marchman for Dallas pass up the right
side Hill I participated in the Stanley Cup
Playoffs gave away with a championship ring here's
Mar moving in with a shot of that sto by ainger
Dallas just a little bit sloppy oer not able to
get to that Puck and follow the bouncing Puck
and then it goes right out in front you know often
times when the play comes out from behind the net
you want to try and be set but there's also a time
where you just have to get as big as possible and
look how wide AER stance is and the positioning
of the glove melio oneing lead over the Dallas
Stars there's Harley with a shot stopped by Hill
has not been really settling down much bu they
doing a couple of ice maintenance here as this
period has gone on I got to be honest with the
ice does look a little a little snowy a little
rough you know to get a whistle it's almost like
if you're the goalie get out there and play it
move it back up you know what I mean like keep
it going got momentum oh what a save there what
a what a redirect by carrying HS lqu for The Far
Side barf still in pain got by lqu stopped
and in locked to the boards by Aiden Hill
he's going to the barbashev is going to the
bench long change here in the second period
barbashev finally off Rich out by lqu stopped
by Hill and then it was Stevenson in OT in game
two all CED in there for Vegas on the bench
getting some attention so Stone has replaced
Conor H sliding into the
boardsi save made on hawen paaw
by Hill barette back out for
Vegas rope hin back out to the left side pelski
got a piece of [Applause] that HS it out to the
left Point again Stars working to round save made
by H loing front another Stop on Lindell and the
puck is underneath the Vegas golender watch this
direct there Ben got a piece of that one and then
that's the Dem man Lindell just flooding the
front of the net from AT&T 5G net camam and
Hill in Period two here in Dallas Mario moves the
puck ahead two-on one Carlson with Conor Carlson
moving it with a shot and that's turned aside
by ainger move the puck ahead another odd man
rush for the golden Knight great back check
by duchane W back out here's McNab MCD cross
eyes wow what a great defensive play stopping
for Tre there's a look at that great play by
San
wow here's hinin moves it deep into the Vegas
end another big save by hill now
the refound attempt it's tough to
get through with guys in shooting Lane
yeah look the way they're going to open
up instead of going from the Blue Line
in you work from the goal line out and
that's what the power play guys that's why
they make the most money there's Maro GL
by AER to your point you go down to the
goal line and you work yourself out from
there good save by AER you can see he's there he's
waiting for that shot as a gold with the game's
only goal back in the first on the power play now
Jamie Ben dropping it back off Jane centering pass
saved by Hill what a pass Danon Robertson and now
back with their original lines prior of the game
against the Rangers sh score in the final minute
of this second period rope hits ties the game for
Dallas quick transition play three on two in
this line we talked about that pizor thought
he would go to at some point and he goes to
him at the end of the second period and what
a pass by Joe Peli I mean that is nasty and
he gets it to hence and he goes five hill
five hill on hole or five hole on Hill Theodore
was worried about the Center Drive of Robertson
and like to see Robertson hold that front of
the net a little bit more on that first look
pass across oh what an opportunity for Johnston
back around off the stick Suter Marchman over
for the stars can't clear theab for Theodore
backand shot save and then AER with another
on Carlson good work here by amadio and then
eventually this puck gets right to the slot and
just a good job by a to read that get across and
an important save again Tyler SGA blows The Zone
and a five on four he thought he was going to
just over four minutes remaining in regulation
J Theodore for the Golden ice long pass up the
left wing and now Stone moving in with a shot
saved by ainger Stone maintains possession SS
it back out broken stick P trelo hustling back
a two-on one in the closing seconds and a shot
clock by [Applause] petrangelo and now Vegas
with the puck for the first time it's eel just
over three minutes remaining in overtime I e
puts on a move walks in eel scores what a goal
Jack eel wins it an overtime for the golden
knights that's the end of the game final score
and finally Kenny you may mention they finally
get the puck watch the play Here by eel he gets
it petrangelo looks like he stays outside watch
he's going to go shoot this Bo he goes to
shoot it and hands on it he stays with it
and he holds he holds and he's able to get oer
down and beat him in overtime what a move and
he doesn't even elevate it too I mean he's
fortunate cuz I'm sure he was trying to roof
that pu sure was but sometimes you get the breaks
I thought a huge play by Hill at the other end of
the ice big poke check he made the save on
Robertson before this whistle took place and